das ist der urlaubs kanzler meine damen
und herren den wir ihnen jetzt zeigen
wollen olaf scholz in nesselwang im
allgäu exklusive fotos bild hat den
kanzler und seine frau an ihrem
ferienort entdeckt guten abend und diese
fotos sind auch besser eine rarität weil
olaf scholz doch tatsächlich der erste
kanzler helmut schmidt ist der mit
seiner frau urlaub in seinem eigenen
land verbringt und wirtschaft reporter
peter tiefe kann uns zeigen wie
olaf scholz ganz leger im dunklen t
shirt und dunklen shorts bewaffnet mit
einem großen stapel zeitungen die sonne
scheint ihm auf sein haupt so sieht
kanzler urlaub aus dieses verträumte
landidylle ist die urlaubs untergrund
für kanzler olaf scholz und seine
ehefrau britta ernst bei 28 grad und
strahlendem sonnenschein genießt der spd
politiker seinen wohlverdienten
sommerurlaub doch nicht an der adria
oder in alicante sondern im allgäu
kaiserwetter und königs panorama hier
macht der deutsche bundeskanzler urlaub
seit 40 jahren hat kein regierungschef
mehr die großen ferien in der heimat
verbracht olaf scholz genießt jetzt das
schöne allgäu bei nesselwang hier hinter
mir im tal und bild macht mit dem urlaub
im knapp 4000 seelen ort nessel bank
legt das kanzler paar jetzt die füße
hoch dieser ort im allgäu ist ein
staatlich anerkannter luftkurort
prädikat besonders gute erholung und die
kann der kanzler gut gebrauchen seit
seinem amtsantritt im dezember ist er im
dauer krisen modus ukraine krieg mega
inflation und corona entspannung lag für
den kanzler stets in weiter ferne jetzt
liegen dort die alten wunderschönes
panorama hohe berge blaue seen saftig
grüne wälder ein bisschen bewegung nach
monaten am schreibtisch in nesselwang
kein problem der kurort ist bekannt für
seine wander und fahrradrouten falls
sich olaf scholz und britta ernst dann
doch nach mehr action szenen auf einer
langen rodelbahn geht sind
höchstgeschwindigkeit vom berg ins tal
da ist der adrenalinschub programmiert
habe ich das alles kann der kanzler
jetzt genießen doch 14 tage urlaub sind
lang für weitere aufregende aktivitäten
gibt tipps von den nesselwanger
einheimischen also auf jeden fall müsste
er so wie wir heute eine ballonfahrt
gemacht haben und sich über das
herrliche alkohol wunderschön auf jeden
fall den breitenberg da waren wir
gestern schon aber der edelsberg und
alpspitze auch tatsächlich sehr schön
als er muss hier auf die alpspitze so
hoch aber zu fuß die kondition besser
wird und dann muss er unbedingt den
kaiserschmarren essen unbedingt so schön
geht urlaub in der heimat das wussten
viele seiner vorgänger wohl nicht
kanzler stolzes der erste bundeskanzler
seit helmut schmidt der in deutschland
urlaub der kanzler der einheit helmut
kohl vor regelmäßig an den wolfgangsee
nach österreich gerhard schröder liebte
la dolce vita hier genießt das leben in
der toskana mit seiner damaligen ehefrau
doris und angela merkel sie verbrachte
ihren kanzler urlaub am liebsten in
südtirol und teilt sich kanzler scholz
nach noch mehr luxus sind nur 20 minuten
und erst im schloss neuschwanstein
ehemaliger wohnsitz von könig ludwig den
zweiten fast genau so pompös wie das
kanzleramt und siehe da der kanzler
macht urlaub für ottonormal wähler ein
ganz normaler bundeskanzler auf
heimat-urlaub und im allgäu ist es auch
wirklich schön
so
zu bild chefreporter peter thiede in den
kanzler urlaub wer den er ganz
offensichtlich auch genießt lieber peter
wir haben schon ein paar tipps ja
gesehen gerade die der kanzler bekommen
hat von uns wie muss man sich so ein
kanzler urlaub vorstellen
ja ganz bodenständig ne also der kanzler
hat eine hat ein ferienhaus gemietet das
stammt aus dem 17 jahrhundert 320
quadratmeter groß bis zu sechs personen
passen da rein und es ist natürlich er
ist der kanzler eine ampelkoalition die
roten mit den grünen sie geben das muss
natürlich politisch korrekt sein drei
jahre lang ökologisch saniert von auf
dem dach sind solarzellen der kanzler
hat eine terrasse für sich und zu seinen
füßen da blickt er nicht nur auf die
berge und auf einen schönen feier
sondern unter ihm la kräuter auch seine
gattin auf dem liegestuhl wir für urlaub
hat der kanzler eigentlich
ja das ist so ein ding kanzler haben gar
keinen urlaub die sind in einem
öffentlich-rechtlichen
beschäftigungsverhältnis und haben der
ernennungsurkunde und in dem gesamten
gesetz das die kanzlerschaft regelt
findet sich eines nicht nämlich urlaub
der kanzler ist nämlich tatsächlich
immer im dienst da sieht man auch hier
er wird nicht nur scharf bewacht also da
stehen container von der polizei vom
bundeskriminalamt ist sind überall in
der region stehen masten mit kameras und
mit anderen überwachungstechnik nein er
hat natürlich auch seinen start mit
dabei es ist im nachbarhaus ist unter
anderem teil des krisenstabes da ist
auch die geheimen kommunikation und
fernschreiber mit dabei dieser kanzler
hat wie die kanzler davor niemals
wirklich frei also er kann aus spannt er
kriegt ein tapetenwechsel aber als
kanzler hat man niemals urlaub
also du hast gesagt er seine frau war
auch dabei und sonnte sich gerade er
starb es natürlich dabei
sicherheitskräfte wie allein sind die
beiden überhaupt dort im urlaub werden
sie da in ruhe gelassen
also sie haben natürlich im
privatbereich da kommen dann auch die
sicherheitsleute nicht rein aber wenn
die beiden sich bewegen wollen dann sind
sie natürlich unglaublich eingeschränkt
also jeder besucher muss voll geplant
werden wenn sie mit der bergbahn mit der
alpspitzbahn fahren wollen hier von
nesselwang aus nach oben dann muss das
vorher angemeldet werden muss die
security hoch dann muss die bayerische
polizei und die bundespolizei die müssen
das absichern wir müssen gucken ist das
alles aber wir haben auch kriegs- und
krisenzeiten das darf man wirklich nicht
vergessen das ist nicht so easy peasy
wie das mal war also das war bei angela
merkel und schröder war das noch ein
bisschen einfacher da gab es einfach
keinen krieg in dem irgendwie verwickelt
waren und man hat also zweisamkeit aber
keine einsamkeit
peter tiede auf den spule bundeskanzlers
den er heute entdeckt hat
prost nach nesselwang im allgäu